it's rainy season in the amazon normally
a time when logging activities and fires
decrease
yet deforestation has been on the rise
during the first three months of this
year
941 square kilometers of the brazilian
rainforest were destroyed
64 percent more than the same period in
2021
official data just released shows first
quarter deforestation at its most
extensive since 2015.
it's the result of illegal logging and
mining but environmentalists also blame
brazil's president jair bolsonaro
we know that this is a consequence of
several um
of the the environmental policy that has
been implemented by the current
government since it took office in 2019
so the surveillance activities were
drastically reduced there is no action
plan to fight deforestation
uh there are several bills that actually
send the wrong message that the people
who who do environmental crime will not
be punished on the other hand they will
they might be benefited with a change in
the current regulation so all of this
leads to a scenario in which
deforestation rates are out of control
again
bolsonaro is pushing for legislation
that will open indigenous lands to
mining
thousands of representatives of more
than 170
indigenous tribes are now in the capital
brasilia protesting against a set of
bills which will make it easier for
miners loggers and farmers to
commercially exploit the amazon
from january to march deforestation in
indigenous lands increased by 52 percent
compared to the same period last year
environmentalists say this is
particularly concerning because those
areas should be protected whereas today
the opposite is true
monika yanaki of al jazeera rio de
janeiro